and the way I took that scene was I'll
see you in 10 years
[Music]
[__] do you know what it feels
like to be 26 years old have people that
you went to high school with come to
your liquor store look you dead in the
face as they pulled up in their BMW and
say oh you work for your dad and then
you ring them up on their case of
champagne and you bring it out to their
car and put it in their trunk and they
look you in the face with pity I Liv
that life and the way I took that scene
was I'll see you in 10 years
[__] I have friends who make
$42,000 a year work 9 to four but
they're pumped and they'll text me like
how happy they are to be the coach of
their kids baseball team and you know
that's amazing I'm actually weirdly
envious but I have friends who have $100
million in the bank who are still hungry
who want to do even more who will
complain to me cuz they know I work a
lot about no work life balance and they
don't get to spend enough time with
their family and I'm like you have $100
million you could stay home like you're
in control don't complain about it
you've made made that choice you want to
spend more time with your family spend
more time with your family how many
people here have used chat GPT or an AI
think I don't think people realize that
Alexa and Google home and apple home are
about to use this for real for real I
don't think people realize it's going to
look like this hey Alexa I have six of
my sons friends coming over two are
lactose intolerant one is vegan three
are a mess and I'd like them to eat it
and I'd like them to eat a little
healthier I only have a couple hundred
bucks in budget and they'll be here for
about 4 or 5 hours but I also need
something quick and snacky in the
morning cuz they're going to sleep over
and I want to send them home with
something send it that's how people are
going to shop so what I just said is
real life in 5 7 9 10 years how do I
know that the person I'm going to hire
is dang it
Gary I've got really good hiring advice
learn to fire fast you guys have your
ego tied up in your hiring you think
you're so good at hiring and then you
hire somebody and they're [__] but you
may pretend they're not because firing
them admits that you were wrong so it's
your own ego that's holding you back my
ego is only balanced by my humility I
hired somebody for hundreds of thousands
of dollars 6 months ago interviewed him
three times I fired him one day into
working at Vayner media I'm like [__]
check your ego in the door you're not
that great of [__] hiring but good
news nobody is there's this clip going
around on the internet where the guy
asked him did he fail this season uh do
you get a promotion every year no right
so every year you work is a failure no
every year you work you work towards
something towards a goal which is to get
a promotion to be able to take care of
your parents you work towards a go it's
not a failure it's steps to success I
love that Giannis did that because
there's so many comps to it right now A
lot of people are realizing what
athletes are dealing with because now
everyone's putting themselves out there
and they're getting commented about
everything about everything about
everything one bad night and everyone's
got all sorts of things to say every one
of us in this room right now we have bad
days but it's hidden it's a very
interesting human psychology
conversation I love that that Viral clip
is going because I hope it helps people
how journalist I'll I'll tell you
exactly how ready I want to write an
article about champagne that focuses on
the fact that prco from Italy is now a
good alternative for a portion of the
price I want you to historically
reference other times in history when
something was the establishment and a
product came along that was equal of
quality but a fraction of the price and
speak to it in a manner that helps
people understand understand that
quality of flavor is subjective but
price is not enter the prompting I just
wrote a very good article for the London
Times about prco and champagne something
will be outputed and then I'm going to
read it and I'm going to add 10 more
sentences and edit six more sentences so
the creativity of the writer and the
ability of the editor becomes a new form
of a human being I just literally talked
out to you
you like some lemonade I would like some
lemonade are you selling any yes okay
well then I want some my friend one so
let's see how this is your first sale
yes it is what's your name Buddy Andrew
Andrew all right pink lemonade all right
that's the good
stuff no you got to give him more oh you
got to that's that's that's good that's
good I like that kind of and then give
that to him all right how much $1 okay
well I'm going to give you 20 is that
okay yeah we got some chain no no you
keep the chain
oh my goodness what do you say thank you
you're welcome thank you so much bro
this is delicious you made this you or
Mom tell the truth H we kind of work
together you're a team yeah all right
thank you buddy have the best day I'm 27
and I'm trying to keep myself going
every day and I kind of struggle
sometimes so what is your take on that
what do you struggle with brother I
think just being motivated to get to my
angle honestly six figures have a big
house I'm being a little materialistic
but well that's that's why you're
struggling you're literally the
hypothesis I have of why people are
unhappy you just made up an arbitrary
goal for yourself based on material
things without realizing the second you
walk into that home and you make six
figures nothing's changed damn that
was I would rather you know have someone
be honest with me you know so but even
better brother I'm telling you from the
deepest levels of love that you can even
imagine I know you I've met a thousand
of you all of them have lost the second
they got there you've been able to turn
your perspective to something that's
very easy to turn your perspective to
the world is very good at selling this
it's just super not true bro 20 years
ago making a million is the way people
talk about making a billionaire it was
that not achievable for almost everyone
yeah and now we all walk around and
these kids are
confused like the okay so America very
rich country one of the richest in the
world the top 1% of earners in America
the bottom the last person in the top 1%
the top 1% is 440,000 a year that's wow
really W let me say real
slow if you make more than $440,000 a
year you're in the top 1% of people in
America n that's I call this the high
school party rule I think this is the
most interesting move in high school
culture if you're a mid tier popular
person you can't be the coolest and you
can't be a nerd and Off the Grid like in
the rank of 300 coolest kids in your
class you are 200 you're below the
middle if you're lucky enough that your
parents don't give a [__] or travel too
much or something else in your
environment if you are able to somewhere
between sophomore and junior year of
high school host the party and get
everybody to come to your house and [__]
on your house but you held it you go
from 200 to 92 to 13 if you think back
to your high school the person that was
not necessarily built to be popular
freshman year who hacked the system was
the one that realized that if they
hosted the party it would Elevate their
brand within the ecosystem if you're
hosting the podcast in a very small
Niche and you're the host and you're
reaching out and saying hey Rick number
one successful commercial real estate
personality in all of Texas I'd love for
you to be a guest on my show they're
like oh [__] whoever can host the party
first wins the
[Music]
langra